let's try Thai from Iowa Ty from Iowa
welcome to the program
hello David can you hear me yes I can
okay so I just wanted to bring this up
because there's just something I've kind
of noticed so I mean this is kind of a
while ago but
I I always kind of notice whenever
there's a shooting they just say like
well there's nothing we can really do
about it because there's you're never
going to stop a shooting by doing this
or still going to happen right
but
um there was a shooting done by a person
that was trans I mean that happened a
while ago and I've never seen people on
the right talk about shootings as much
as they did with the angel just came up
yes and I was like do you realize how
many people have done shootings that
were like neo-nazis and right-wing
extremists and all this other stuff yeah
I mean I don't know it just doesn't
really make a lot of sense to me it kind
of feels like they need to save
this side that I don't like is the one
doing it that's when I can actually care
about this issue and actually
acknowledge that it's an actual issue
but I won't focus on the fact that
I don't know like maybe
people did this because they're
propagated and all this other stuff they
people might listen to what I say and
then I go out and commit violence or
the
there really isn't the gun restrictions
on the United States really aren't
strong enough people keep getting all
these guns United States is the only one
with this problem and I'm like just one
happens and it's just kind of they go
nuts and I was just kind of I don't know
I guess what do you make of that yeah
and I I mean to focus in on what you
said a lot of different things many of
them most all of them valid
um one of the particulars that you
mentioned is this idea of well there's
no way to prevent every mass shooting
like if someone's really determined blah
blah blah you know we've heard that
before and it's it's a very silly
argument because aren't we still better
off if we dramatically reduce the number
of mass shootings or we reduce the
number of people killed in each mass
shooting like these are still all worthy
goals and it's sort of like hey you know
seat belt laws aren't going to save
people if the car uh ends up at the
bottom of a lake okay right but in some
scenarios the seat belts will save
people so we should still do it and then
let's figure out what to do about the
drowning maybe we need better guard
rails on Bridges and you know things
like this it's a similar sort of idea
and it's um it's it doesn't even
remotely pass the I seriously want to
fix this test when people start with
you're never going to prevent every mass
shooting or there's no way to stop a
truly determined person well a lot of
people are aren't maybe as determined
and they would be dissuaded by any of
the 10 or 12 different initiatives I've
proposed so it's not a serious argument
when people start with that that's it's
defeatist and it's uh unrealistic in
terms of finding improvements that we
can make and there's many improvements
we can make
yeah I mean it applies to a lot of other
things I just think that was probably
the one that sickened me the most was it
just kind of felt like they were just
using
um the lives of people that were killed
and all this other stuff just to to be
transphobic and it just kind of happens
that was kind of disgusting all of a
sudden they have 10 ideas of how we
would prevent shootings by trans people
and they all involve denying people
gender affirming care and uh not not
using their preferred pronouns it's
crazy it's a crazy situation
yeah
that's unfortunate yeah all right Thai
from Iowa thanks for the call
thank you for taking my call David all
right there goes Ty let's go next to
Jessica from Indiana Jessica from
Indiana welcome to the program what's on
your mind today hello hello can you hear
me yes I can
perfect perfect so I do want to go ahead
and say I am from Indiana I do want to
go ahead and apologize for Mike Pence
apology accepted yeah so I am a brand
new voter I uh just recently with my
first uh local election with it being uh
speculated that Ronnie is going to be
running for the Republican nomination in
like next week uh Trump having even more
accusations of corruption and sexual
harassment and so on how do you see the
near future of American politics being
especially for a young person in a very
very red State like Indiana I hate to
say this but I think until the 2024
election is resolved I don't think we
are going to see any serious adult
policy conversations about materially
improving the lives of young people in
red States I do believe that Joe Biden
has done a lot of little things that are
good little things on Health Care little
things on student loans Etc and I think
to the extent that he's able to act
unilaterally he will but this election
is shaping up to be such a mess that I
just don't think there's going to be the
bandwidth for serious National
conversations about substantive policy
that will move us more in the direction
of where we want to go so my message to
young people in red states where things
aren't going well this is a sad message
and it's not a realistic one for many
people but it's if you want to
immediately improve your circumstances
you may want to consider moving to a
state where things are already better if
you don't think you can wait it out at
least until 2025. I hate that that's
what's going on but I will say one more
thing that's a little less negative
which is that there are still
opportunities
to make other types of improvements if
you get involved locally and that might
mean City Council in Indianapolis or
whatever the case may be I don't want to
say that there's no opportunities to
make progress but from the federal
discussion it's going to be a mess until
the next at least until the next
president is inaugurated yeah I will say
Indianapolis is relatively good I mean
we just had we just elected a um
Democratic Socialist to city council
here in Indianapolis so that's pretty
cool there you go
and uh once one final question uh so
myself and my family do have to drive
out of state uh typically to missing
Michigan uh to enjoy ourselves some
marriage Awana some marriage date if you
will uh when do you think that wheat is
going to be legalized in all 50 states I
honestly have no idea I I genuinely
don't know could it could it be five
years could it be ten I I'm not sure I I
think that there will be some red state
holdouts for a very long time
um
well fair enough thank you so much all
right Jessica from Indiana thank you
very much for the call why don't we go
next to Dev from Syracuse Dev from
Syracuse New York welcome to the program
hello again David how are you I'm doing
well
I have a question for you today that's
not related to politics well everything
is Loosely but I hope that excites you
um something that's very important to me
is the live event Music Space uh I've
been going to concerts since my early
20s regularly all year every year and
some thing that I've been seeing that's
very concerning is a lot of Acts or
festivals uh
basically not able to continue in the
way that they envisioned their event to
to take place because of the
Stranglehold from Live Nation and
Ticketmaster which are only the same now
uh there's some estimates that Live
Nation Ticketmaster own uh over 70 of
all live event space at this point the
United States yeah uh so I think there's
a big problem when the artists aren't
able to
uh you know make the event the way that
they plan on it I mean music itself is
an art
it should be expressed in from an
artist's perspective in my opinion at
least
um not so corporatized I'm curious if
you yourself attend live music uh with
any frequency and what's your take on
this corporate takeover of something
that I truly love so the corporate
takeover of the ticket sales I have been
speaking about for more than a decade
it's outrageous between the
consolidation as well as the fees
unmitigated disaster and I've been
crystal clear about that as far as me
attending live music I used to attend
music very regularly when the pandemic
started I stopped attending live music
events and I haven't gone back and I'll
tell you why it's a couple different
things my tolerance for the crowds and
the parking and the security line and
the traffic on the way out the bumper to
bumper in the parking lot and all of
this stuff I've lost my patience for it
Dev I really have maybe a I've just
gotten too old for it and then number
two you know let's be honest the body
odor and the ten dollar Waters and the
entire thing I just like I did it for
decades I've been to endless shows I
love music I'll listen to Live albums
all the time but it has not piqued my
interest to get back to live music
events since uh since the pandemic
fair enough I mean to each their own I I
still Revel in the body odor and well I
don't like the 10 Waters I love crowds
and the excitement the activity meeting
new people yeah one of my favorite
things about it besides the music itself
well this is the great thing about
America you can go and I don't have to
and everybody's better for it I just
wanted to give a shout out to summer
camp music festival I'll be attending uh
that next week unfortunately it's
another one that is going to go on an
unknown term Hiatus due to difficulties
with logistical challenges they didn't
spell it out in plain English but I have
my suspicion that it has a lot to do
with this corporatization of life event
where is that event held that's in
Illinois oh okay you know I'll be
driving this is so insane this was one
of my my worst Live Concert Experience
was
um I went to this insane right-wing
nuttery thing called Country Thunder now
I know people will say David not
everybody's a right-wing nut who goes to
Country Thunder okay the environment was
total right-wing nuttery in in like
Wisconsin this was like 15 years ago or
a long time ago I got roped into it by
people who like country music which I
don't like and uh it was an absolutely
fetid environment I mean it just just it
was a never again moment for me
hey goof I'm sorry that you had to go
through that but hey I appreciate your
time David thanks so much there is Dev
from Syracuse going to have at it at the
live music events exciting exciting
stuff all right everybody that's where
we're getting to today we will take a
break I will take calls again that
unless they silence me
which they're trying to do by the way
who is they I don't know unless they
silence me we will take calls again uh
and we will also be right back after
this extremely short break